all right the scene in macau china today
it's the gambling haven of the world and
it's been shut down or will be for at
least another week right now as covet
cases uh begin to flare up there 25
million shanghai residents by the way
are separately being asked to be
retested to see if things are spreading
there as well and we're seeing limited
movement in hong kong on the same story
so it's repeating itself in asia it's
jarring those who think thought that at
least we were over this at least there
that is not the case and there are
spikes in cases here as well dr anthony
fauci knows of what i speak he had to
endure covet himself and a pretty bad
case of it the white house chief medical
advisor joining us now doctor good to
have you how are you feeling
i'm doing real well neil thank you for
asking i'm actually fully recovered and
i'm essentially back to normal thank
goodness now you were
you know being treated again uh
was there a flare-up after the flare-up
what was going on there
well what happened is i was initially
infected and given my age uh at being a
risk person at my age i took paxlavid
right and it successfully diminished the
symptoms pretty effectively
and then when i finished the course
i tested myself on a monday i was
negative tuesday negative wednesday
negative but then on thursday
it reverted back to positive
so simultaneously with that literally
within 12 hours i started to get a
return of symptoms with fever with aches
with um you know some little bit of a
cough not very bad so i went back on pax
levitt for another five days
that cleared things up very well
and now i've been negative for multiple
multiple days since then so i'm doing
very well thanks um let me ask you about
this because when people heard oh my
gosh this has happened you know to dr
anthony fauci uh everyone knows someone
who's gotten this again and sometimes
again after that and uh they're
beginning to wonder
about the regimen for treating it uh you
know
whether you get two vaccination shots
whether you've got a booster another
booster
they just don't know what do you tell
them
well i that that's a great question and
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to clarify it neil there's no doubt that
the vaccines themselves particularly
vaccine plus a booster at the
appropriate time when you become
eligible for a booster
for more than one booster if you're over
50 years old you get eligibility for two
boosters one of the things that's clear
from the data
that even though vaccines because of the
high degree of transmissibility of this
virus
don't protect overly well as it were
against infection
they protect quite well
against severe disease leading to
hospitalization
and death and i believe that's the
reason
neil why at my age
being vaccinated and boosted even though
it didn't protect me against infection i
feel confident that it made a major role
in protecting me from progressing to
severe disease
and that's very likely
why i had a relatively mild course so my
message to people
who seem confused because people who are
vaccinated get infected
the answer is if you weren't vaccinated
the likelihood you would have more
severe course than you did have when you
were vaccinated
but you know there are a lot of people
looking at this especially with this new
strain i can't even keep up with the
doctor even though if i'm pronouncing it
right this ba 2.75 or what have you uh
it always seems to be mutating it always
seems to be spreading and yet the
collective view of the world is we are
over this time to move on time to live
our lives time to fly again we're no
longer forcing those who are coming in
from other countries uh that they've
either been vaccinated or testing
negative for the virus itself so how do
you feel about all this
well we are certainly not over it and i
think that you know people have an
understandable desire to put this in the
rear view mirror and say we're through
with it but that's just not the reality
neil and when i say that i don't mean to
scare people to get people feel they
have to dramatically alter their lives
or do anything with mandating a thing
like that we're not talking about that
we're talking about making
use of
the available interventions that we have
let me give you an example
67 percent of the people in this country
are vaccinated we rank very low among
developed and developing nations
in the proportion that are vaccinated of
those who were vaccinated
only about half of them have gotten
their first boost again we've got to do
better than that we're giving the virus
the opportunity to continue to spread in
our community
and if we do simple things
which are not disruptive in any major
way
vaccination boosting testing for example
if you're going to go to a function you
want to get tested to make sure you're
negative so that if you are infected and
you have minimal symptoms you don't
spread it if you have a vulnerable
person in your household someone who's
on chemotherapy or immune compromised
you might want to test regularly to make
sure you don't inadvertently bring the
virus home to a susceptible person those
are relatively easy things to do neil
and yet we're not doing enough of it and
that's what i'm trying to get the
message out we don't want to disrupt
your life we don't want to force you to
do anything but do some common sense
things that have been proven to be
effective
all right so very quickly then doctor if
people are are realizing yes the number
of cases have spiked pretty much across
the globe nothing like what's going on
in china but they're not severe cases
they're very few hospitalization cases
although they're spiking as well that
makes americans in particular say
been there done that over that what do
you tell them
well i tell them it's understandable
with that attitude but be careful we are
still having an increase in
hospitalizations
we're having many more infections than
being recorded we're saying it's about
140 000
a day
those are grossly undercounted because
many people who get infected do a home
test and don't report it and we are
still at around 300
deaths per day that is an unacceptably
high level neil so although people kind
of say been there done that
well we're at a level that is not an
acceptable level for us we've got to do
better than that
all right i know this was tough on you
because you missed your daughter's
wedding at least to be there in person
because of this coveted scare so i hope
everything went okay you're okay yeah
yeah i'm fine and thank you for asking
neil really appreciate it all right dr
fauci thank you very very much hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now